tengo una hija que tiene 13 años pero en
el 2012 cuando fue el colapso financiero
que se cayeron todas las bolsas del
mundo y todo eso tenía 5 - que ahora
tendría 89 años
y estábamos viendo el noticieron
estábamos almorzando viendo el noticiero
y apareció un tipo de corbata pelado un
periodista que siempre daba malas
noticias fue el que vaticinó el del
tsunami y que se cayó un avión y ese día
dijo último momento se desplomó la bolsa
en todo el mundo y mi hija me miró así y
yo me puse pálido y siguió el tipo y se
se disparó el valor nominal del bono por
no poder sostener las obligaciones de
deuda y mi hija me miraba
la banca de inversión colapsó dijo el
tipo se están suicidando los accionistas
y me abrí los ojos grandes yo también
obviamente me asusté porque estaba
pasando algo grave y entonces ni na mi
hija que siempre me preguntaba qué es el
tsunami que es el avión que se cayó y
era fácil explicarlo del tsunami en el
epicentro de una cosa en el mar que
después de ponerlo filipino es simple me
pregunto qué es esto que pasó ahora papá
es grave y yo me di cuenta que no tenía
la menor idea de cómo explicar a un
chico qué cosa era eso un terremoto se
explica fácil pero como le explicas a un
nene el colapso del sistema financiero
no se lo podés explicar porque es
intangible más que nada pero como soy
cabeza dura y alguien ratos libres soy
escritor o también me propuse hacerlo
así que escribí un cuento un cuento
infantil y al día siguiente cuando
estábamos mirando de vuelta al noticiero
y me volvió a preguntar lo que hice fue
contarle una historia que quiero
compartir con ustedes
le digo al débil yanina ese día que
había una vez un pueblo muy tranquilo y
que había un muchacho que llamaba pepe
el protagonista que vivía en la casa más
alejada del pueblo una tarde pepe salió
a caminar y le agarró seda cuando volvió
a su casa abrió una botella de vino y
mientras tomaba el vino descubrió una
cosa que nadie había descubierto nunca
no había bares en el pueblo no había ni
un bar al pp pensó que se abría un bar
podía hacer felices a otros dándoles de
tomar y además también pensó que podía
ganar alguna moneda y se puso contento
con la idea de abrir un bar a esa tarde
su amigo moncho pasó por la casa de pepe
y le dio un buen nombre para el bar y ya
se sabe que cuando una idea trasnochada
tiene un nombre ya empieza a caminar esa
idea
entonces pp hizo una lista de
necesidades para abrir el primer bar del
pueblo ni ná me miraba con los ojos
abiertos el cuento estaba bien no hasta
ahora
pepe se dio cuenta que hay que comprar
mesas sillas copas pinturas un palenque
para que los clientes del bar pusieran
sus caballos y pudieran entrar a tomar y
saco las cuentas y todo eso le iba a
costar unas diez mil monedas
por supuesto pp no tenía 10.000 moneda
porque era pobre pero durante la noche
se le ocurrió una manera de conseguir
esas diez mil monedas pp recordó mil
papelitos y escribió en cada papelito la
frase próximamente bar de pepe mil veces
escribió eso y el domingo después de
misa se fue a la plaza del pueblo
vestido con su mejor traje y le dijo a
todos los vecinos en la plaza queridos
vecinos voy a abrir un bar en las
afueras del pueblo todo el mundo lo miró
qué buena idea dijeron algunos pp se
sintió muy bien con la atención de todos
y entonces mostró en abanico los mil
papelitos recortados y dijo esto es
importante ni ná le dije yo dijo pepe
cada uno de estos mil papelitos cuesta
diez monedas los vecinos lo miraban
el que me compre un papelito va a tener
que guardarlo porque dentro de un mes
cuando yo habrá mi bar voy a pagar 12
monedas por cada papelito que ustedes me
devuelvan
entonces hubo susurros en toda la plaza
y moncho que era el tonto del pueblo
preguntó para pepe pero no cuesta diez
monedas cada papelito porque vas a
regalar después dos monedas más y pp
dijo no es regalar mucho es compensar
voy a compensar con dos monedas más a
los que me ayuden a cumplir mi sueño que
es abrir un bar entonces el alcalde que
estaba por ahí se acercó y dijo tiene
sentido tiene mucho sentido muy bien pp
y ernesto que era rico y entendía de
negocios dijo a mí la idea me parece muy
bien y el pura ricardo sacando algunas
monedas de abajo de su sotana dijo es
una idea muy cristiana
yo quiero algunos de tus papelitos y
todos empezaron a comprar papelitos de
pepe de esa manera es tan simple y en
una sola mañana pp consiguió la plata
para abrir su bar entre todos los
vecinos de comprar en los mil papelitos
yo le compré dos dijo sabino que era
pobre pero optimista yo le compré 36
gritaba aquí que que era codicioso y
altanero
pepe se fue a su casa con 10.000 monedas
en la mochila y se durmió pensando en su
sueño abrir un bar al día siguiente era
lunes y pp viajó a la ciudad y compró
madera para construir un máster un
mostrador y compro pintura volvió a su
casa y se puso a trabajar no pasó por la
plaza del pueblo en las siguientes
cuatro semanas es decir le dije ni ná pp
no se enteró del desastre que se iba a
armar por culpa de sus papelitos en ese
momento del cuento yo frené y me quedé
mirando a mi hija para ver si estaba
entendiendo la historia siempre hay que
testear las metáforas con los chicos
sobre todo cuando son ideas complejas y
ella me dijo papá esto no tiene nada que
ver con lo que dijo el señor pelado de
la tele pero está bueno seguí
entonces le conté le conté lo que pasó
en el pueblo durante la primera semana
es el lunes la plaza estaba llena de
gente mucho más de un lunes normal
muchos vecinos habían pasado la noche
entera recortando sus propios papelitos
porque también habían descubierto tenían
proyectos que no podían cumplir por
falta de monedas
unos papelitos decían en breve heladería
de horacio otros papelitos decían muy
pronto peluquería de carmen e incluso
había unos papelitos escritos por moncho
con faltas de ortografía que decían a
fin de mes haré viajes a la luna
de pronto los vecinos se subían a las
farolas de la plaza para que los otros
vecinos pudieran comprar esos papelitos
se treparon a la fuente para
intercambiar papelitos por monedas el
martes fue todavía peor y el miércoles
ya no se podía caminar por la plaza del
quilombo que había
el alcalde tuvo que poner orden y
habilitó un lugar cerrado en la
municipalidad para que los vecinos
pudieran reunirse para intercambiar
papelitos sin destrozar la plaza este
pequeño local se inauguró el jueves y
fue bautizado con el nombre del salón de
los papelitos y así fue que el viernes
todos los que tenían un proyecto ya
habían conseguido las monedas necesarias
para llevarlo a cabo y se habían puesto
a trabajar
horacio ya buscaba leche crema hielo
para su heladería pp que estabas a
luchando la madera para el mostrador del
bar carmen afilaba las tijeras para su
flamante peluquería y moncho había
comprado dos caballos flacos para hacer
viajes a la luna
solamente quedaban en el salón de los
papelitos un grupo de vecinos a los que
nunca en la vida se les había ocurrido
ningún proyecto interesante lo único que
tenían estos vecinos eran papelitos de
otra gente uno de estos vecinos ramón se
quejó en voz alta caramba dijo ahora
necesito monedas para comprar cigarros
no tengo hace unos días cambio en mis
últimas diez monedas por un papelito de
pepe y ahora necesito fumar a mí me pasa
lo mismo dijo louis quiero ir al cine no
tengo una moneda las quejas fueron cada
vez mayores hasta que sabino que era
astuto levantó su papelito y dijo a ver
muchachos dentro de tres semanas pp le
va a pagar doce monedas al que le
devuelve este papelito que yo compré a
diez vendo mi papelito ahora mismo por
ocho monedas
y los otros los mineros
trato de hecho dijo ernesto que era rico
pero quería hacer todavía más rico y le
sacó de las manos por ocho monedas el
papelito
ramón y wish también vendieron sus
papelitos por menos de 10 monedas y
mientras uno querría comprar cigarro y
el otro se iba al cine los demás vecinos
vieron que aquella era una nueva forma
de hacer negocios aunque nunca en la
vida se les hubiera ocurrido una idea de
verdad
algunos se subieron a las cifras otros
se subieron a las mesas empezaron a
ofrecer lo que tenían e incluso el cura
ricardo llegó de la iglesia triste y
dijo amigos del día que moncho puso a la
venta sus papelitos yo que soy cristiano
le compré unos cuantos porque es tonto
ahora mucho los vende a siete monedas y
dice que va a devolver 20 monedas pero
es tonto y quiere hacer viaje a la luna
yo ahora necesito monedas para arreglar
el campanario y nadie me quiere comprar
los papelitos de moncho
lo siento padre riccardo le dijeron
todos nos podemos comprar que moviera la
luna ese muchacho entonces el cura se
fue del salón con los papelitos de
moncho cabizbajo y fue la primera vez en
muchos años que nadie lo estaba ayudando
a reparar la iglesia y así pasó la
primera semana entonces la mira ni ná
que me dijo ahora me parece que empieza
a parecerse a lo que dijo el pelado de
la tele y yo le digo claro en el mundo
real el salón de los papelitos se llama
la bolsa de valores mientras que los
papelitos pueden tener dos nombres
se pueden llamar bonos en algunos países
en otros países se llaman obligaciones
las 12 monedas que va a pagar pp cuando
el bar funcione o las 20 monedas que
dice moncho que va a pagar cuando haga
viajes a la luna se llaman valor nominal
del bono minino número 6 y abrió los
ojos grande porque entendía la chica
ocho años entonces le conté lo que pasó
la segunda semana en el pueblo le conté
que la casa de [ __ ] ya no parecía una
casa la casa de pepe parece otra cosa en
el comedor había una barra de madera el
baño se había convertido en dos baños
uno para damas otro para caballeros las
paredes estaban a medio pintar de azul
marino y pp estaba contentísimo con los
progresos de su bar
como todavía no había ido al pueblo pp
él seguía sin saber que la vida de sus
vecinos era un quilombo de papelitos que
iban y venían cambiando de precio y de
dueño incluso el alcalde después de
hablarlo con su secretario decidió
sumarse a la nueva moda una mañana de
martes el alcalde salió al balcón con
megáfono y dijo vecinos la plaza quedó
estropeada después del furor de los
papelitos necesito recaudar fondos para
arreglar los destrozos de las farolas
para renovar la fuente y para comprarme
un coche a motor desde este momento
pongo a la venta mil papelitos oficiales
cuánta moneda cuestan pregunto sabino
nada de moneda dijo el alcalde mis
papelitos cuestan un caballo cuando la
fuente eche agua cuando las farolas
vuelvan a la luz se obtenga un coche a
motor
voy a devolver dos caballos por papelito
los papelitos oficiales están a la venta
desde ahora corran que se acaban
los papelitos del alcalde se vendieron
en tiempo récord todos en el pueblo
entregaron sus caballos al alcalde y
desde ese día las tareas se empezaron a
hacer a pie mientras tanto el
intercambio de papelitos siguió en
aumento y ya no alcanzaban los lápices
para notar quién era el dueño de que
algunos papelitos eran muy deseados por
ejemplo a los de pepe que trabajaba día
y noche en la concreción de su bar pero
a otros papelitos no los quería nadie
por ejemplo los de moncho porque su
artefacto para hacer viajes a la luna
por el momento solamente constaba de dos
caballos y un carro nadie creía que eso
empezará a levantar vuelo
ernesto el vecino rico que había
comprado muchos papelitos durante la
primera semana
ahora se quería sacar de encima los
papelitos de moncho y como también tenía
papelitos de pepe inventó algo buenísimo
a lo que bautizó los fajos de ernesto
eran paquetes cerrados con 100 papelitos
de todos colores por ejemplo había diez
papelitos del bar de pepe arriba
20 papelitos de la heladería de horacio
al medio y 70 papelitos del proyecto
lunar de moncho abajo sin que nadie
viera
el jueves de la segunda semana los fajos
de ernesto tuvieron un gran éxito entre
los vecinos que buscaban como locos
papelitos de pepe o del alcalde pero el
viernes quique descubrió el truco y dijo
cuidado vecino cuidado los fajos de
ernesto a veces vienen con papelitos de
pepe o el alcalde en la parte de arriba
y eso está bien pero el fondo del
paquete hay un montón de papelitos de
moncho que nunca en la [ __ ] vida va a
hacer ningún viaje a la luna así que
antes de comprar frascos de ernesto
busquen mi consejo mi tarifa por cada
consejo es dos moneda
desde entonces los compradores de
papelitos consultaron siempre aquí que
antes de comprar de fajos ernesto
ernesto y [ __ ] que habían sido amigos
durante muchos años dejaron de hablarse
para siempre y así pasó la segunda
semana a esa altura ni ná era casi una
experta en todo este asunto yo le
expliqué que en el mundo real los
papelitos oficiales del alcalde se
llaman títulos de deuda pública le
expliqué que los fajos de ernesto
reciben el nombre de obligaciones de
deuda mientras que la casa de quique el
lugar a donde van los vecinos para saber
si confían o no en los fajos de honestos
se llaman banca de inversión
entonces le conté a nina que cuando
empezó la tercera semana en el pueblo
algunos proyectos que estaban casi
terminados y en cambio otros seguían en
pañales apt solamente le faltaba clavar
el palenque para que los caballos de los
vecinos
bastarán fuera del bar ahora se había
conseguido batir leche y frutas para su
heladería y nomás le quedaba a traer
barras de hielo desde la ciudad
en cambio carmen todavía no había
encontrado un buen local para instalar
su peluquería aunque ya tenía docenas de
tijeras afiladas y que decir de moncho
pobre moncho sus caballos estaban cada
vez más flacos y tristes aunque lo se
pisaba el día y noche y no parecía que
su artefacto pudiera volar en menos de
una semana los vecinos que tenían
papelitos de moncho de carmen estaban
inquietos y ya no podían vendérselos a
nadie hasta que apareció quique con una
gran idea oigan dijo quique los que
todavía tengan papelitos de moncho no se
preocupe yo les puedo vender
tranquilidad de quique para esos
papelitos
y eso que pregunto sabino que tenía
muchos papelitos de moncho muy fácil
dijo que el que tenga papelitos demonio
me paga dos monedas cada noche de acá a
fin de mes y si moncho no consigue hacer
viajes a la luna yo pago las 20 monedas
prometidas por moncho aunque muchos
fracasos se preguntaron todo aunque
fracase dijo quique tremenda idea dijo
sabino así no se nos vamos a sentir
mucha más tranquilidad y podremos
comprar más papelitos del tonto del
pueblo por eso mi idea se llama
tranquilidad de que el que dijo piqué y
muchos vecinos empezaron a pagarle aquí
que dos monedas por noche para asegurar
el proyecto de moncho en el medio de la
euforia por estas nuevas ideas nadie en
el pueblo notó que el alcalde nunca
había arreglado las farolas ni la fuente
de la plaza el alcalde haya cumplido con
una parte solamente de la promesa
a día
escapado del pueblo con un coche motor
era todo lo que había hecho
en los únicos caballos que quedaban en
el pueblo eran los demonios todos los
demás se los había llevado el alcalde el
secretario que había sido mano derecha
del alcalde conocía la estafa desde el
principio decidió hacer algo para que
nadie descubra la ausencia de su jefe y
su idea fue estupenda trajo al salón de
los papelitos una pizarra y empezó a
ponerle nota del 1 al 10 a cada proyecto
al bar de pepe le puso un 8 a la
peluquería de carmen le puso un 5 a la
galería de oración 7 al vehículo para
hacer viajes a la luna de moncho le puso
un 2 y haciéndose el distraído a las
reformas de la plaza del alcalde les
puso un 950 qué significan estos números
preguntó sabino y el secretario dijo son
las posibilidades de concreción de cada
proyecto es para ayudar yo lo hago por
ustedes
y así pasó la tercera semana en este
punto yo le expliqué a nina que en el
mundo real
la idea de quique de ofrecer
tranquilidad sobre los papelitos demonio
deja más seguros de impago de deuda y la
gran pizarra donde el secretario le pone
una nota a cada proyecto en el mundo
real se llama agencias de calificación
que a veces se equivocan sin querer y a
veces se equivocan queriendo entonces
mira me pregunto si finalmente pp había
logrado abrir su bar porque ya estábamos
en la cuarta semana y le conté el final
de la historia el final de la historia
dice así cuando llegó la cuarta semana y
se cumplió el mes pp se levantó muy
temprano y caminó tranquilo hasta el
pueblo de lejos se vio la fachada de su
bar con el cartel luminoso a todo trapo
el bar se llamaba la luna como lo había
bautizado moncho el primero día ahora
solamente faltaba que llegaran los
vecinos a caballo con las gargantas
muertas del pp recorrió las cinco leguas
hasta el pueblo poniendo carteles en
todos los árboles del camino bar de la
luna
todas las noches cada cartel que ponía
se iba lejos y se quedaba orgulloso
mirando el cartel
sin embargo cuando llegó a la plaza del
pueblo no entendió nada de lo que estaba
pasando hasta pensó que se había
equivocado de camino que estaba en un
pueblo diferente parecía que por ese
pueblo hubiera pasado la guerra las
farolas y las fuentes de la plaza
estaban destrozadas no había un solo
caballo en las calles y los vecinos
caminaban en redondo hablando solo qué
pasó acá le pregunto pp horacio cuando
lo vio al pp dijo horacio llorando ay pp
todo el mundo enloqueció con los
papelitos con los míos con los de carmen
con los tuyos con todos de repente
empezó a ver más papelitos que monedas y
el alcalde se escapó del pueblo después
el nuevo moneda más tarde desaparecieron
los caballos los vendedores de fajos del
aneto quebraron los revendedores de
tranquilidad de aquí que no pudieron
pagarle a nadie y se escaparon a la
noche estamos en la ruina pp y tu
proyecto de nada preguntó pp y la
peluquería de carmen no lo mío fue un
fracaso dijo horacio no hay caballos por
ir a buscar quiero la ciudad y el helado
se derrite y carmen no tiene cliente no
ve que está todo el mundo arrancándose
los pelos solo
que quieren peluquera pp se quedó en
silencio no podía creer lo que le
estaban contando entonces horacio dijo
ay por dios necesito algo fuerte y louis
dijo yo también tengo una garganta seca
y xavi lo pregunto pp abre esto y no
abriste el bar que querías abrir y otros
también se acercaron a preguntar por el
bar pepe descubrió entonces que sin
caballo nadie iba a poder ir nunca a su
hogar en las afueras del pueblo y
entendió también que jamás podría
devolver las diez mil monedas a nadie y
entonces vio en el medio de la plaza a
moncho
los dos caballos flacos de moncho eran
los únicos animales que quedaban y
arrastraban tres carros con dos ruedas
cada uno en forma de tren a esos carlos
se iban subiendo muchos vecinos y otros
hacían una fila larga esperando para
subir
moncho preguntó pp a dónde va todo esta
gente y moncho dijo a dónde va a ser a
tu bar a la luna pp vio un cartel
colgado en la fuente rota que decía
moncho hace viajes a la luna salidas una
moneda regreso gratis pero a moncho
preguntó pp vos sabías que todos iban a
quedar sin caballos lo dijo moncho yo
solamente hace una cosa yo lo que sé es
que la gente puede ir a un bar a caballo
pero nadie puede volver borracho y
montando un caballo y como yo no tomo
pensé que mi negocio podría ser
llevarlos y traerlos de la luna entonces
pp abrazó a moncho se subió el primer
carro y gritó vamos todos a la luna
bebidas gratis la primera noche y todo
el pueblo subió y aplaudió ni ná
incluso aplaudió contenta el final de la
historia y entonces yo le dije a mi hija
que tuviera cuidado porque en el mundo
real las historias de los pepes que
intentan abrir bares o las historias de
los monchos que quieren hacer viajes a
la luna y nadie los entiende son casi
siempre proyectos que no suelen tener
final feliz como en los cuentos
infantiles porque en el medio aparece en
tickets aparecen alcaldes aparecen
ernestos y secretarios y lo echan
siempre todo a perder pero cuando alguno
de estos proyectos si funciona le dije a
mi hija para terminar cuando estos
proyectos funcionan cuando algo mágico
pasa y funcionan se llaman sueños y
suelen ser maravillosos
muchas gracias